hi I'm Matt Welch for recent TV i'm here
at Freedom Fest in Las Vegas the old
friend of reason Rob Campea executive
director of the Marijuana Policy Project
Rob thanks for joining us sir we've had
a pretty interesting last year and a
half with legal marijuana in Washington
and Colorado update us on what's
happening there and what is coming up in
the near future in the marijuana burger
the governments of Colorado and
Washington are actually faithfully
implementing the will of the voters so
there will be marijuana businesses
selling two adults in both states
starting in the early part of 2014 the
terms of the of the piece right there
are we winning the piece in addition to
winning the war in Washington and
Colorado well you know we do escalated
or eliminated the war and we have good
relationships with government officials
there so it's peaceful I think the next
state to legalize will be Alaska for a
ballot initiative that we're running in
August of 2014 the polling is good it's
a cheap state we can do it through state
legislatures I think the first state is
going to be Rhode Island because almost
everyone in the legislature is extremely
liberal and our bill is already halfway
to passing and then you're going to see
a whole bunch of states voting on
legalization initiatives in 2016 all in
the same day which would be California
Nevada Arizona main maybe Massachusetts
for the last 15 years as the medical
marijuana movement especially has gone
forward everything good that has
happened and I'm speaking roughly has
happened because of voters mostly and
the ballot initiative project are we at
a point now where we can finally start
saying good things happen because of
politician or politicians who are not in
spite of politicians well we saw with
medical marijuana is that the ballot
initiatives came first and then state
legislators started passing the bills
and then Congress started getting
interested in it but of course not
passing anything I think you're good to
see the same thing with legalization
ballot initiatives first Rhode Island
will be the first legislature and
Congress is starting to pay attention
congressman Dana Rohrabacher is Bill
Republican from orange county is a
really good legalization bill on the
federal level and he is talking about
making this one of his top priorities in
the years
left in Congress is there anybody who's
the vying for a spot in 2016 besides
Rand Paul who's talked about this in any
way shape or form not that I'm aware of
finally going out here feels like
there's been a public sea change of
attitudes right we have now pretty at
least tenuous but real majority of
Americans who want to see marijuana
legalized what happened medical
marijuana allowed people to talk
sensibly about marijuana generally
because before that it was all a lot of
scare tactics and government lies people
were able to talk about marijuana
sensibly that it could actually be good
for you it's not always bad for you that
grandmother's use it it's not just
teenagers conservatives use it it's not
just hippies when the real conversation
came out you saw support for
legalization increasing as a result
we're now fifty two percent support for
legalization which is a higher level of
support than for most politicians so
what is your current prediction of the
year that this is all in the rearview
mirror I think federal law by prediction
JG federal law is going to be 2019 but
we're going to have to deal with a lot
of difficult States after 2019 like
Mississippi and Alabama awesome thank
you very much for recent TV with Rob
can't be I'm Matt Welch